if you wanted to argue with me that you  wanted to do this behavior or act in a  certain way  and what you were saying was hey Jocko  you're kind of a [ __ ] because you don't  want to do this or you're not going to  allow this or you don't want us to do to  act in that in that way my trump card  was real simple and real straightforward  and it won a hundred percent of the time  it was the ace of spades  you'd rather go out and get drunk they'd  go and fight al-qaeda if that's where  you're at [ __ ] you I don't want you on  my team I'd only want to be associated  with you if any of you do anything that  prevents us from going to war I will  never forgive you and I will hate you  forever there's a group of human beings  on this planet that want to destroy our  way of life and I have the opportunity  to go and hunt them down you're gonna  take that away or you're gonna put that  in any kind of risk not happening